this is the front page story The
Washington Post as Congress approves the
stopgap measure evading a shutdown the
house passing it in the afternoon and
the Senate early in the evening we're
going to take a short break and when we
come back joining us from Nashville
Tennessee is Stephen Mansfield he is the
author of the book God anger hope and
why Christian conservatives supported
him choosing Donald Trump later bill
press will be joining us you are
watching and listening to c-span's
washington journal it is a getaway
Friday as many head out for the
Christmas holiday Friday December the
22nd we are back in a moment
Sunday on c-- span's QA Heritage
Foundation Distinguished Fellow Lee
Edwards chronicles his 60-year
involvement in the conservative movement
I met Joe McCarthy through my father who
was something of a confidante to him and
he was a hail fellow well met
he liked the party he'd like to drink
her too and as long as you didn't talk
about communism you couldn't ask for a
more fun guy to be with but he's very
serious about that and it was also
someone who did not take advice very
well and he consequently said things and
even did things that hurt the cause of
vani communism for some time Q&A Sunday
night at 8:00 Eastern on c-span
for the next week Washington journalist
featuring authors of key books published
this year starting Saturday at 8:00 a.m.
Eastern join us for our live
conversation with authors about their
popular books on Saturday FH Buckley
with his book Republic of virtue how he
tried to ban corruption failed and what
we can do about it Sunday Michael Eric
Dyson talks about his book tears we
cannot stop a sermon to white America
and on Christmas Day Monday author Henry
Olsen with the working-class Republican
Ronald Reagan and the return to
blue-collar conservatism Tuesday ken
stern with Republican like me how I left
the liberal bubble and learned to love
the right and then on Wednesday angela
jay davis with her book policing the
black man thursday former representative
cliff stearns with his book life in the
marble palace and praise of folly also
on friday december 29th author and
scholar Harun Ola with digital world war
Islamist extremists and the fight for
cyber supremacy and then on Saturday
December 30th
Jessica brooder with her book nomadland
surviving America in the 21st century
and on Sunday December 31st author Chris
Whipple with the gatekeepers how the
White House chiefs of staff define every
presidency Washington journals authors
series for the next week at 8:00 a.m.
Eastern on c-span c-span org and c-span
radio
[Music]
Washington Journal continues joining us
from Nashville Tennessee is author
Stephen Mansfield his book choosing
Donald Trump God anger hope and why
Christian conservatives supported him
thanks very much for being with us on
this Friday one year into his presidency
do they still support him not to the
same strength that they did initially
there's been some drop off some buyer's
remorse
estimates are 10 to 15 percent of the
support he had in the election from Evan
Jellico's from religious conservatives
has dropped off and that's for various
reasons but yeah there's been a little
bit of loss why well different reasons
some of them don't like his manner some
of them don't like him picking a fight
with the mayor of San Juan Puerto Rico
during the hurricane I've heard from a
great many of Angelica's who didn't like
him calling NFL players who knelt during
the national anthem sob is that that
kind of approach they don't like now I
imagine he'll his stock will rise among
religious conservatives given the recent
tax bill the passage of the tax bill but
but there are various various reasons I
think heaven Jellicle czar like anybody
else any other group they're very
diverse and they have various reasons
for perhaps souring a bit on on Donald
Trump but but I think he's lost maybe 10
to 15 percent of Evan Jellicle or
religious conservative support earlier
this month you wrote a piece that's
available on the Washington Examiner web
site and this is the headline at
rethinking Donald Trump the evangelical
dilemma and you wrote the following
quote American religious conservatives
are Wed to Donald Trump now they will be
made to answer for the the mores the
methods the machination zuv the Trump
administration perhaps it is just this
connection to their seemingly untethered
president that is causing some religious
conservatives to have second thoughts
perhaps they sense that if Trump fails
them if he portrays their vision the
banner of religious conservatives may be
forced from the field of American
cultural battle for a generation or more
explain well we have to go back to the
2016 election a year ago and realize how
much full-throated support Donald Trump
had from religious conservative let's
remember that he that he pulled 81% of
white evangelicals
half of all roman catholics and half of
all regular Church attenders not only
that but some of the most prominent
religious voices in our country where
we're absolutely in support of Donald
Trump in fact they engaged in sort of a
religious rebranding of him they said he
was Churchill he was Lincoln he was
Darius the great he was some compared
him to Ronald Reagan so they didn't just
you know sort of generally say hey we're
happy about a few of his policies but
we're concerned about his personality in
his you know raw a manner they just
almost joined his PR team they got in
bed with him as we now say in our crafts
phrase so they own him you they they we
go into the Trump presidency with
evangelicals aligned with Trump and the
popular understanding and we've seen
that there are the articles I'm sure
you've seen them Steve in the Washington
Post New York Times is there anything
Donald Trump could do that would lose
him Evan Jellicle support are they just
completely supportive of him and the
answer from some leading evangelical z'
has been well Donald Trump gives us
access that no other presidents given us
so it feels transactional it feels like
there's a bit of a deal and so in the
popular understanding and the
understanding of the electorate no
question that evangelicals religious
conservatives now in our slang phrase
own Donald Trump they they are
responsible for him and if he fails them
that they will suffer serious damage
already we're seeing a bit of that with
Millennials with evangelicals of color
there's a bit of distancing there's a
bit of fraying of the coalition so to
speak so yeah there's gonna be some
payback if this goes badly in the Trump
administration and one of the points in
the book because you and these are your
words you say quote America's Christian
core is in crisis they have chosen a
candidate whose personal life is at odds
with the values he has promised and
defend and you're calling it a
controversial book well I'll leave it
others to decide whether the books
controversial but I think I'm reporting
the facts I trust I am the fact is that
no no evangelical no American religious
conservative would have gone into a
laboratory so to speak and come out with
Donald Trump as the ideal candidate for
years religious conservatives have
talked about the personal morality of
presidents or people they supported have
wanted godly statesmen etc this is the
language
that would be used and so now they have
Donald Trump a man who may be on some
kind of Christian religious journey of
his own at this stage in his life but
further throughout most of his life has
has not been an exemplar of the values
that religious conservatives hold so now
they've got a man that they are happy
with because he's championing some of
their political values but at a personal
level whether we're talking about
marriages and affairs and language etc
he is not the exemplar of what they
believe so they're there doing a bit of
a balancing act and it's a it's a
potential it's it's a balancing act
that's fraught with danger for them it's
it's it's got some threat to it it's
it's a difficult dance for them to do
and I think we see this in some of the
religious leaders so yeah it's a it's a
tough tough issue for them and it has
definitely brought division not just
families that don't have Thanksgiving
and Christmas together anymore but again
and I said every 81% of white
evangelical supported Donald Trump but
Evan Jellico's of color I've heard them
say hey I guess it didn't matter to you
white evangelicals that this man was a
racist or Millennials say hey I knew how
could you possibly support this man in
the name of Jesus Christ whom you say
you follow and and not not recognize how
raw and crass and violent he is so there
are there are fractures happening in the
religious conservative world over Donald
Trump to other points before we get to
our viewer and listener calls the role
of the Vice President Mike Pence who by
the way is in Afghanistan today meeting
with the troops how significant was his
selection and his role currently into
this White House very significant if
we're talking about really from a
religious perspective he was sort of the
guarantee to Trump's religious base that
he was serious about winning them he was
serious about hearing their counsel pen
mr. pence as a Roman Catholic who's who
who who names himself as an evangelical
which means he's conservative he's
traditional in his theology and faith
and so that he would be at Donald
Trump's elbow guaranteed evangelicals
that they would have more than just a
representation and a voice but they
would have some power actually within
the administration so this was extremely
important to religious conservatives do
you wonder in their personal
conversations because
as you and so many others have mentioned
you could not have two more different
people in terms of their own personal
life than Mike Pence and Donald Trump
well I think the only way to understand
that is there is some evidence that
Trump has in recent years begun a more
conservative religious journey he had
always been in church he was raised
Presbyterian he was impacted as I think
we all know by the famous norman vincent
peale but he wasn't much of a churchgoer
in his in his middle life he wasn't a
very religious man he'd make public
statements about even about things like
adultery being okay and things like that
but in recent years he's been under the
influence of some religious conservative
leaders and he seems to be on some sort
of a journey it's a little hard to
understand but like like many presidents
towards a deeper religious journey and I
think this made him value a man like
Donald Trump so yes you've got two men
who are very different have lived very
different lives and draw attention for
very different reasons but this is
evidence I think of a shift in values in
Donald Trump in maybe the last decade or
so and yet based on his schedules we
don't see him going to church often no
you know it's interesting he's a man who
talks about his Christianity and his
Bible reading etc but once norman
vincent peale stopped pastoring
collegiate marble Collegiate Church up
in Manhattan Donald Trump stopped going
to church regularly so you might fly off
to Camp David and there might be a
chapel service but you're right he's not
making the effort to at least appear to
be in church regularly as other
presidents have done and let me ask you
about that race in Alabama and Roy Moore
of course president Trump initially
supported Luther strange in the primary
then was all in for Roy Moore he lost in
that Alabama Senate race and a lot of
questions about his own personal life
and what happened when he was in his 30s
with allegations of some teenagers back
in the 1970s and 80s what does that tell
you about the president and evangelicals
and that race in particular in Alabama
among Alabama Republicans well I think
Evan Jellico's people who have a moral
grid who are there on the conservative
side of the political spectrum had to
hold their nose to support Roy Moore
nobody was happy about it
but there's a lot in the balance the
Senate is quite close and so to lose a
couple of seats would really lock up the
Senate so I think that people stuck with
Rory more wondering if the allegations
were true wondering if the some of them
women weren't put up to you know that
convinient missions the allegations they
were making I don't think we can read
too much into it
frankly think Roy Moore should have
stepped down and let another man run for
office but but the bottom line is nobody
that I know in DC and I live there was
that happy about Roy Moore and most of
them were just holding their nose and
supporting him not because of his
personal morality they were opposed to
that but rather because he they needed
the help in the Senate
our guest is Stephen Mansfield the book
is choosing Donald Trump let's get to
your phone calls still Tim is joining us
from noir field Minnesota independent
line good morning Tim I just good
morning I just I knew that I wasn't
gonna vote for this guy when I saw his
first rally I mean he he was inciting
violence and there was a protester in
there and so one of them styled Trump
supporters went and popped him right in
the face and I heard Donald Trump say
get them out of here I'll pay your legal
bills I mean I'm just I'm surprised that
the evangelicals are anybody that calls
themselves a Christian there's gonna
support this guy I'm hearing these
little sound bites all let's Trump be
Trump no no I don't like the guy I think
he's I think he's a violent man I think
I think he's unstable and everywhere
everything he does he seems to divide
people so anyway that's my comment have
a good day Tim thank you
Stephen Mansfield any response yes I do
i I have to say that the caller is
absolutely correct about Donald Trump in
deciding violence I mean we may not like
it we may want to overlook it some
people but the fact is at his rallies he
did offer to pay the legal fees for
people who were beating up on protesters
he did mouth from the stage on more than
one occasion to protesters I'll kick
your blank
you know letting them know that he
personally would do the violence and a
couple of times at rallies he said when
people were hitting each other and
police were trying to pull him apart he
said the problem is nobody wants to hurt
each other today so you know call it
irresponsible call it off-the-cuff if
you want but the fact is the colors
right there is a tension here between
the Christianity that Donald Trump
espouses and supports and encourages
with men like pence at his elbow and
some of the things that happen during
his rallies the caller is absolutely
correct from your book the following
quote Donald Trump was carried into the
White House by an angry tribe they felt
themselves being sidelined by history
and feared their country as they knew it
was slipping away they want to change at
nearly any cost and they look beyond
more experienced candidates to set their
hopes upon the sharp tongued
hard-hitting angry as they were a
billionaire from New York he won them by
promising to give their country back to
them and to win a future for their
children they believed him largely
because he spoke of faith like a
crusader like one who understood
religion as a perpetual call to arms you
explained yeah you know it's it's a hard
perhaps for us to understand but there
are is a stripe of American society a
portion of American society that
celebrates the very things that folks
and other parts of the country decry
about Donald Trump that he was violent
that he was raw that he was harsh
that he was willing to whoop up on
protesters that he spoke in angry terms
this was all positive and I have a
chapter in the book where I talk about
that you know the fact that you know the
people of the media people up north were
I where I live a good more in the DC
area might decry Donald Trump for some
of his anger and crafts nests and
harshness and divorces but average
Americans especially conservative more
southern Americans I'm from the south
myself they this is how they speak
around their table they felt comfortable
with him there is angry as he was they
sometimes speak about whooping an old
boy you know and andaman man needs a
beating and and they too have divorces
and they too have foul language and they
too have some perhaps a nominally racist
attitudes that they're not that
but when they hear Donald Trump speak he
sounds like you know for many Americans
what goes on around their breakfast
table so these very factors that make
him a pariah amongst a morsel use the
word sophisticates not to be pejorative
makes makes him feel like one of us to
certain portions of the country and I
and I think that's the dichotomy I think
the book hillbilly elegy that's gotten
so much attention explains a slice of an
of a disenfranchised angry underclass
largely white in America that came out
for Donald Trump and great strength
because they feel these very things and
so the anger he was the more the Kraft
sir he was with his language the harsher
he was that even even the nominally
racist denominator violence they
resonated with all of this and so his
anger sounded a trumpet call to them and
they showed up for him our next caller
is from portage in Michigan Gary
Republican line welcome to the
conversation with author Stephen
Mansfield go back to Puerto Rico I find
it hard to believe that a country that's
smaller than the Upper Peninsula is AUP
there's a three and a half million
people and they're on there are a
hundred and twenty million dollars in
debt and because he got angry about
giving them another nine hundred billion
dollars I meant to say a hundred and
twenty billion with a be billion I'd say
those people are pretty irresponsible so
he was tagged as a racist because he
didn't because he got mad at the
governor they don't there's three ways
you could create wealth you either line
it build it or grow it apparently those
people don't do any and they're going to
be two hundred billion dollars in debt
if it gives them more money I mean at
some point should somebody have said hey
you know we're like five hundred million
in debt here these people are carrying
us maybe we should you know get a job or
could having so many children or
whatever their issue is and as far as
Trump on I appreciated him in his job
and house
pence and I never heard the guys saying
anything I didn't like and I don't
believe he's ever slug to anybody but um
in some of those rallies if I would have
been there I would have felt like
slugging somebody you know those people
that were heckling him and stuff
deserve to get their get
thank you for the call mr. Mansfield
well you know I certainly think there's
some economic issues for us to work out
with Puerto Rico I think we all know
that that's sort of an unsettled
situation and sure there's a there's a
deficit there the time to address that
is not when the male mayor of San Juan
is standing elbow deep in the waters of
Hurricane Emma and so when Donald Trump
takes her on says she's being put up by
Democrats it you know this is this is
I'm gonna use the word that a lot of
Americans just roll their eyes at but
the optics aren't good you know that's
not the moment that you want to be
picking a fight if we're gonna solve the
problems of Puerto Rico make a mistake
make them pay their bills whatever it is
you want to do do that at another time
but not when people are dying starving
living off bologna sandwiches for a
month at a time etc so that that's that
is I cite that not because I'm taking a
side at this moment but because it's
it's one of the optics it's one of the
moments in the first year of the Trump
presidency that has caused him to lose
some supporters don't pick on people
when they're drowning no matter what you
might be right about you simply look
like a bully and that's how he came off
and yes it lost him some support
especially among evangelicals Josh do
see a political back in October wrote
the following here is the headline why
evangelicals love Trump the president
doesn't come off as particularly
religious but he is skillfully courted
evangelical leaders and from the value
voters conference in October here's what
the president said the American founders
invoked our Creator four times in the
Declaration of Independence four times
how times have changed but you know what
now they're changing back again just
remember
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Benjamin Franklin reminded his
colleagues at the Constitutional
Convention to begin by bowing their
heads in prayer religious liberty is
enshrined in the very first amendment of
the Bill of Rights and we all pledge
allegiance to very very beautifully one
nation under God this is America's
heritage a country that never forgets
that we are all law every one of us made
by the same God in heaven when I came to
speak with you last year
I made you a promise well one of the
promises I made you was that I'd come
back
[Applause]
and I don't even need your vote this
year that's even nicer but I pledge that
in a trump administration our nation's
religious heritage would be cherished
protected and defended like you have
never seen before
that's what's happening President Trump
back in October at the value voters
conference and Stephen Mansfield what
did you hear there well what I hear are
those tones being sounded that could
easily have come from Ronald Reagan
could easily have come from George W
Bush and by the way presidents on the
other side of the spectrum that's the
that is the standard kind of tone that
sounded and by the way my Bill Clinton
when you want to say look I understand
our religious heritage in this nation I
understand the intentions of the
founding fathers and I'm gonna champion
those myself we've heard that a lot from
our presidents I think two things make
it especially poignant when it comes
from Donald Trump first of all is what
we've been discussing and that's his own
lifestyle and you wouldn't have expected
this some people have called him the
pagan brawler you know from New York the
real estate magnate who took no
prisoners and took off his opponents
heads to be espousing these values but
the other thing is we have to understand
that for the average religious
conservative by the time you came to the
2016 election they had experienced eight
years of what they consider to be a
traumatic Barack Obama administration
they felt like there had been a war on
Christianity this this language was
actually used there had been threats
against the green family of Hobby Lobby
for not wanting to offer a board of
faison's in their employee insurance
coverage there had been legal threats
against small orders of nuns there had
been a strident pro-abortion agenda a
strident LGBT agenda and all of that
very traumatic to religious
conservatives so as they came to the end
of the Obama years they turned and
looked and saw the likelihood of a
Hillary Clinton presidency and saw eight
more years of the same so they were
ready for anyone who could win so this
is this is sweet music - there
years this is sweet music to those who
thought they wouldn't hear these words
coming from a chief executive for
perhaps a total of 16 years because this
is not the way that the Barack Obama and
Hillary spent Hillary Clinton speak so
all of that to say that the applause
that you hear and the whooping and the
celebration is that there's the idea
attitude surface saying that Donald
Trump may not be the ideal Christian man
he may not be the holiest president that
we've ever had but at least they would
say he shares he understands and shares
our values on these all-important
religious liberty and religious heritage
issues and and that is manna to their it
to there to there souls that's healing
to their souls given what they feel like
they've been through we are getting a
lot of tweets including this from Mary
who says I actually know why
evangelicals support Trump it is a false
church that follows him one based upon
the prosperity gospel and want to share
with you some exit poll numbers Steve
Stephen man so this is from the
Washington Post on the 2016 election and
how the religious vote broke down
looking at these numbers white
evangelicals supported Donald Trump at
the rate of 80 percent the Protestant
non evangelicals supporting Clinton at
59% Trump at 52% the Jewish
self-described Jewish faith 24% for
Trump 71% for Clinton and those of the
Mormon faith 61% for Donald Trump well
this is this is part of the divide that
you see you know when people speak of
the church or religious Americans or
even religious conservatives they're not
aware that there are divisions within
those factions within those groups that
are often aren't discussed all Evan
Jellico's did not go for Donald Trump we
see the Jewish community divided we see
the Mormon community divided I said
earlier that half of all church goers
are regular churchgoers in America when
for Trump but the corollary of course is
that half of all church goers regular
churchgoers did not support Donald Trump
so we have a great many divisions within
the religious community in the United
States and Donald Trump put it put his
foot right on those divides right where
those lines were
and so he's very polarizing there's a
great deal of tension I can name not
just families that have split church
those churches that have split
denominations that are in tension over
these issues and so religion is one of
the great fault lines that in America of
course American culture but that Donald
Trump in a sense exacerbates however
inadvertently and tongue-in-cheek this
is from one viewer of course President
Obama loves religion look at what he did
for the Islamic Republic of Iran and
there's this you can respond if you want
well I wrote the book the faith of
Barack Obama and I fought the claim that
Barack Obama was a closeted Muslim you
know and all of this these assumptions
about his closeted Islam but the fact is
his wrist is a Christian liberalism his
theological liberalism causes him to see
all religions as pathways to the same
God to the same place as he once said in
an interview so yes he reached out to
the Muslim world he felt somewhat
comfortable having lived there in
Indonesia as a child having had a Muslim
father and so he reached out to the
Muslim world and seemed to be ever
apologizing and ever reaching to what
many Americans consider to be our
enemies so people were offended like
your caller is by the fact that he was
both apologizing for the US and
attempting to bolster the Muslim world
that comes I think not from the fact
that he was ever a closeted Muslim but
from his theological liberalism that
causes him to see Islam as an equally
valid with religion with Christianity
and the only reason I make that
distinction is not that I'm in tension
about that but that most Americans
especially religious conservatives don't
see Islam as an equally valid religion
and are surprised when a president makes
that case and that's exactly what Barack
Obama did in a tweet more of a statement
is from Skeets
who says I'm so sorry all of you don't
appreciate that mr. Trump is making
America great again yeah I mean this is
the sort of the bottom line for people
who support Trump we can put up with his
divorces we can put up with his language
we don't mind if he threatens a
protester or two especially of that
protester has darker skin we don't mind
if he's angry and
raw and engages in petty Twitter Wars at
3:00 in the morning the fact is the
economy is strong we've got a good man
on the Supreme Court finally and he's
making America great again and so we can
look in the faces of our children and
say you have a bright future I mean that
message simple as it is you know what
four letters Magna Maga make America
great again that is the the sort of I
don't want to say it's an excuse but it
is the basis it is the thing that the
force the idea the concepts that causes
many Americans religious of my own
conservatives among them to overlook any
flaw Donald Trump might have if indeed
he will make America great again and
that's also part of attention within the
religious community in America is that
not a form of idolatry some would ask is
that not over excusing a man who is
doing damage and other areas though he
may be helping us to make some military
and economic progress to give you a
sense of where the president is as he
prepares for his State of the Union
address and the return of Congress in
January a tweet just a short while ago
he says quote at some point and for the
good of the country I predict we will
start working with the Democrats in a
bipartisan fashion infrastructure will
be a perfect place to start
after having foolishly spent seven
trillion dollars in the Middle East it
is time to start rebuilding our country
exclamation mark let's get to your phone
calls Dave in Washington DC Democrats
line good morning good morning how are
you you mentioned that mr. Trump has
recently in the last few years as you
put it been on a quote religious journey
this is a man who according to the
Washington Post lies about 2000 times
during the first six months of his
presidency three times a day during the
campaign who of course said on the
access tape that he could grab a woman
by the pee you can do that of you're a
star who encouraged to voters to hit
others and who in charlottesville
encouraged Nazism saying that there were
good people amongst them and this is a
ideology that is explicitly
non-religious and that explicitly
encourages the extermination of entire
races so if we look at this man with
those actions and consider him as being
on a religious journey that is a very
strange religion and I think we would
have to call up the religion of
narcissism thank you Dave
even as field well I agree with
everything the caller says about the
facts there's no question that Trump did
all of that at the same time and I can't
defend it but I can explain it to some
agree he is under the influence of
people like Paula white and other dr.
Jeffers from First Baptist Dallas and
others that he listens to he is by all
accounts deepening in his faith he is
receiving correction from them being
I'll use the word discipled perhaps
mentored would be the more neutral word
by them so I don't think there's any
question he's on some kind of religious
journey now at the same time I validate
everything the caller said about these
statements and the the lies and I'm the
Washington Post is my hometown
newspapers so I know exactly what the
call is referring to and this is the
tension of Donald Trump I can't help
reconcile those two you have a man who
on the one hand makes the kind of
statements that we just heard in the
clip who says he's a champion of
religious liberty who talks about the
gospel of Jesus who talks about a war on
Christmas the Johnson amendment all that
we've heard and at the same time will
lie apparently according to the post at
the same time we'll treat anti white
supremacist protesters and white
supremacist protesters as though they're
this say at the same level of
culpability I can't I can't reconcile
that but I can report it you've got two
things happening at once the crass harsh
often bumbling Donald Trump in his
public statements and a man who is
definitely by all accounts on a deeper
religious journey and so welcome to the
world of Donald Trump and this viewer
typical quote Christian values it's
perfectly okay when there is a quote
good man in a stolen supreme
kourt's eat horse reference to neil
Gorsuch with the passing in February of
2016 of Antonin Scalia and that seat
remaining vacant until after the
election yeah I mean you have to
understand that if you survey most
religious conservatives in America
particularly of angelical 'he's the
thing they have their eye on the most is
the supreme court they feel like they've
been most damaged whether we're talking
about abortion we're talking about the
obergefell case regarding gay marriage
same-sex marriage we're talking about
religious liberty hits most of that
comes from the Supreme Court
so most religious conservatives would
say they would put up with almost
anything from Donald Trump if he just
helps turn the tide on the court so
Gorsuch is the symbol the promise the
hope and they're there of course hoping
for two or three more like just like
that during the the Trump administration
but that covers a multitude of sins and
Donald Trump's life and the thinking of
a lot of religious conservatives Stephen
Mansfield a hypothetical but if you look
ahead to 2020 and hypothetically if the
Senate Democrats regain control of the
upper chamber and there is a sudden they
could see on the Supreme Court with the
tides be turned hard to say hard to say
you've got to have confirmation but the
likelihood is that the tide would be
turned it's it's fairly hard unless
there's some serious ethical challenge
to refuse a Supreme Court nominee I mean
you can drag out the process but
Republicans were of sufficient strength
even if there is a slight turn at the
midterms that I think they could get in
almost anyone who Donald Trump would
would nominate so I I think we will see
more Trump nominees on the court I think
they will be conservatives possibly not
as conservative as Gorsuch but but still
in that stripe and I think they will did
that Donald Trump will have given the
chance to change the culture of the US
Supreme Court but I asked a question
because the Republican leader Mitch
McConnell blocked even a confirmation
hearing for Merrick garland and I'm
wondering if a Republican a Democratic
leader Chuck Schumer would do the same
if that were to happen in 2020 they
would they would almost certainly try
but I don't think they'll have the
strength even with something of a
democratic tide a tidal wave at the
midterms I don't think the numbers are
there that they can
completely block and by the way the only
reason the garland was sidelined is
because it was the end of the Obama
administration we won't be talking about
the end of the Trump administration by
that point so I think that I think the
Donald Trump may very likely change the
culture of the Supreme Court I'm not
sure the Democrats can do anything in
the next few years that would change
that and is joining us from Pleasant
Valley New York Republican line good
morning morning
Merry Christmas see you guys hey I got a
little bit on the religion part I was
born and raised baptized Catholic my mom
had four children
my dad left us she was seeking help
through the Catholic Church when lo
behold she was in trouble because she
was getting divorced okay I'm not a
practicing Christian but I saw what my
mom went through when we were children
and it was hard for her to try and get
through life and then in her later years
before she passed away she became a
born-again Christian and it gave her
some peace to her life but the problem
is in our society is wrapped up in it is
that okay religion whatever you might be
it brings peace to you if you can find
it and and I feel is as our country has
slid into a really bad state we have our
younger generation our rebel rousers I
worked all my life for a local college
watched it and the people don't see what
goes on behind the doors of the early
gates of a college you know women and
men both are are equal they talk like
dogs they they treat each other like
dogs there's a lot of stuff that goes on
people don't say and my point here is we
can't hold a man that's willing to help
try to do something with this country
you know a bound B because he's a man
and there's a lot of men and there's a
lot of women in this country and when
the Republican Party denounced him for a
couple comments who were made behind the
scene and it was on a hot mic you know
oh well you know this is life and this
is what we go through
thank you we'll get a response
well your caller confirms something I
said earlier in this our time together
and that is that he is hearing in Donald
Trump what he perceives to be the way
people are what happens perhaps around
his dinner table we have to forgive
people we have to forgive people in the
church we have to give them a bit of a
pass for misbehavior there they're
trying to do good they're trying to be
good people Donald Trump's trying to
make America great again
so which we can't really you know hold
him to legalistically to his faults and
his flaws and his and his failures so
the caller is doing a good job of saying
hey this is the way it is this is what
religion does we learned to forgive we
got to let this man off the hook for
some of his misdeeds and obviously
that's the the kind of thinking and I
say this positively that allows someone
who sees Donald Trump's flaws to
nevertheless vote for him that he this
caller has perfectly represented what
obviously a huge number of Americans
feel when it comes to Donald Trump
they're not stupid they're not blind to
his failures but they but they believe
in forgiveness and they certainly
believe in giving forgiveness to a man
who perhaps is able to make America
great again that's that's it in a
microcosm right there let me remind our
audience listening on c-span radio
coast-to-coast on Sirius XM or on the
web at c-span org that we're talking
with Stephen Mansfield he is joining us
from Nashville and the book is called
choosing Donald Trump God anger hope and
why Christian conservatives supported
him Tony is next Littleton Colorado
independent line Good Friday morning go
ahead Tony
good morning mr. Mansfield I am I find
your topic in your presentation
fascinating and interesting
I am stipulate I I was lost when I have
daughters and when I heard his comment
about I walked in on pageants the
teenage pageants and look at these women
and you know and it's and it's you know
and he can get away with it because he
owns the pageant you know I I couldn't
look at my daughter's and then go for
her to never support him so I was lost
so at least know the position I come
from my question is around the populace
and so here I ran a campaign based on
fear and anger and some violence and and
at minimum passive aggressive racism and
and so
peel the the fears of well this make
America great again
my question really is what would will
happen if for example the tax plan that
is so targeted at the very wealthy
rather than the middle class if he lets
down his followers on this on the
populism that he ran it will they even
turn away then or will they always be in
his camp with kind of his you know I can
shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue and my
followers would never leave me is that
will that be true even if his
quote-unquote populist measures like tax
plan is kind of really kind of revealed
to how much of that 80 some percent
going to the top one percent so it's
really well what happens if populism
fails that he promised thank you very
much Tony thank you I think everybody at
every every group religious or not has a
line that a candidate they previously
have endorsed can't cross for you it had
to do with how you had to look in the
face of your daughters and couldn't vote
for Donald Trump if if this was what was
being said about women and how women
were be were being treated I don't mind
saying here on the air that for me it
had to do with African Americans I have
African Americans and my family I'm in
an African American largely African
American Church in DC and I couldn't
look my nephews and nieces and friends
in the face and and be a full-throated
for Donald Trump despite the fact I'm
slightly right-of-center conservative so
everybody has a line at some point I
think you're making a good point and
that is that you know if if he fails in
some of these things if his if his
populist message does not win him the
points despite his misbehavior in missed
statements would they with his
supporters ever abandon him and I think
that we can't speak of his supporters
and as a generic Bunch
as a generic group there are there are
different factions different values
different hot-button issues but I think
that all support can go away when you
cross certain lines
apparently when it comes to Donald Trump
Donald Trump his supporters are far more
forgiving than they have been with other
certainly conservative candidates and
certainly people on the
side of the aisle but we do know that at
some point there is some line in the
sand that if Donald Trump crosses for
them yeah they will eventually abandon
him it just seems to be a little further
down the road than it is for other
people you and I couldn't couldn't
continue with Donald Trump earlier and
in the process some of these folks would
have to see something pretty severe
before they would abandon him but yeah
it could certainly happen from Sikeston
Missouri Kay is next on the Democrats
line thank you for waiting good morning
thank you for taking my call and mr.
Mansfield you do seem to be one can a
person one can have a rational
discussion with and it may take a few
statements for me to get to my point I
do believe that the main objective is to
pronged for the Republican capitalists
and that is to kill the working class by
destroying the unions and the abortion
issue which is an imposition of your
religious view of when life begins on me
if I can in our small town in America's
heartland my husband and I find
ourselves amidst human debris of the
political and economic establishment
ruinous policy okay thank you for the
call we'll get a response well I like
first of all hearing that somebody
thinks they can have a rational
discussion with me on the air that that
pleases mate that's my Merry Christmas
president but the caller is articulating
an interesting perspective small-town
America devastated by as she calls it
the the economic policies of the elite
and and yet she's unable to go with
Donald Trump she sees his policies as
exacerbating the issue this is the other
side of flyover country small-town
America perhaps people who are
conservative in their soul but but but
move a little bit further left because
of what they see happening economic in
our society and
this caller I think this recent caller
represents a growing number of people
who are concerned about the policies of
Donald Trump see them exacerbating some
of the economic problems they deal with
and then hold some progressive views on
social issues like what she said about
abortion so that that that group that
faction that part of the electorate is
still in play and they may have a lot to
say in the midterms
Leeroy from Midland Michigan independent
line with Stephen Mansfield go ahead
please yes I totally agree with you mr.
Mansfield I think a lot of people who
came out to vote for Trump was you know
against more or less the direction that
a lot of people feel like we're heading
to to me Larvik goes back to the Supreme
Court decision on same-sex marriage you
had three four states that had ballot to
ban same-sex marriage 31 of those states
passed that ban and then the Supreme
Court they took all those votes in those
31 states more or less just trash I mean
that's the Micra stages they didn't
weigh with it
I think that irritated a lot of people
they came out to vote for Trump and and
this is where we're at it's just my
opinion thank you thank you well and I
should say that the same thing happened
in 1973 with roe v-- wade the Supreme
Court abortion decision state-level
decisions were thrown out to a huge
degree and the reason I cite that is
that this is what causes that religious
base that supported Donald Trump to fear
the Supreme Court and to be so thrilled
at his intentions the Supreme Court has
been this is going to by man over state
to make a point here the Supreme Court
has been to a large degree the enemy of
religious conservatives almost almost
every major trend or every major
decision that religious conservatives
and America are concerned about fear see
as a violation of God's will as they
understand it it takes a few stems from
the Supreme Court or culminates perhaps
in a Supreme Court decision so the idea
that there's someone who is expressing
as much anger as they feel and who has
the power to change the the culture the
direction of the court makes them
willing to overlook a great deal we've
already said that but I think it's
important for us to recognize that so
the caller again represents a portion of
American society that is willing to say
I don't care if Donald Trump Custer has
30 wives the fact is he's going to help
change the direction of this country and
as I said earlier semi humorously that
covers a multitude of sins what it
conclude with this tweet from Beth Moore
and she tweeted it out one day before
that December 12th special election in
Alabama she of course is the wife of Roy
Moore you can do what you want but I'm
not giving up without a fight we've let
evil overtake the entire reputation of
evangelism the lust for power is
nauseating she writes racism appalling
the arrogance terrifying the misogyny so
far from Christlikeness
it can't be Christianity what's your
takeaway well Beth Moore's a friends of
mine and I agree with her completely and
she from the beginning of the sexual
abuse allegations and issues and and
character questions about some of the
Republican candidates held her line she
herself has has a me-too story as many
women do and she is probably by virtue
of her theology and politics of being a
right-of-center like I am but but she is
saying look there's no reason and it's
that in fact it's an offense that
conservative politicians conservative
statesman candidates should be people of
low character we've compromised we've
looked the other way
we need valiant champions of
conservative causes she might use the
word right just cause us and we don't
need to look the other way or somehow
cover over their misdeeds particularly
when it comes to abusing women so Beth
represents I believe a great many women
out there who lean conservative in their
politics have traditional Christian
values but have no intention of winking
at the misdeeds of candidates
particularly when it comes to sexual
abuse and I think we're gonna be hearing
a lot more for them and I'm glad for it
before we let you go the book titled
choosing Donald Trump what
thing did you learn what surprised you
in putting this together I think the the
one thing that I ate one moment probably
is the thing that most impacted me
Donald Trump speaking at Liberty
University arguably the largest
Protestant undergraduate school in the
world is champ
is making a speech of their convocation
championing religious liberty talking
about the war on Christmas and then he
gives them some business advice and in
that advice is you know screw your
enemies get get even with your enemies
apparently not recognizing that the the
person upon whom Liberty University is
founded Jesus Christ taught exactly the
opposite and this and I only cite this
as we close because this is again that
conundrum of Donald Trump that on the
one hand he espouses these religious
values supports religious conservatives
but on the other hand doesn't quite
understand the full claims of the
Christian gospel particularly when it
comes to Christian ethics so we can say
let's fight the war on Christmas on one
hand and let's screw our enemies on the
other and you know America that is the
Donald Trump that we have right now and
this is what we're grappling with in
this interview it's been good to be with
you by the way Steve Steven Mansfield
the book is choosing Donald Trump God
anger hope and why Christian
conservatives supported him joining us
from Nashville Tennessee we thank you
for being with us
have a Merry Christmas merry Christmas
to you in just a moment we're gonna open
our phone lines tell us what is on your
mind our lines are open at two zero two
seven four eight eight thousand one for
Republicans in 202 seven four eight
8,000 for Democrats if you're an
independent - OH - seven four eight
8,000 - we'll also read your tweets at
c-span WJ and you can join in several
hundred of you already have on our
Facebook page at facebook.com slash C's
Ben actually now over a thousand this is
a photograph from the Washington Times
vice president Mike Pence a surprise
visit yesterday to Afghanistan at the
Bagram Air Force Base here's a portion
of what he told the troops under
President Donald Trump the armed forces
of the United States will remain engaged
in Afghanistan until we eliminate the
terrorist threat to our home
and our people once and for all
[Applause]
you know really is humbling for me to
stand before you today my my father was
a combat veteran served in Korea and I'm
the proud father of a United States
Marine but my life never took me into
the uniform of the United States but
every time I'm I'm with men and women of
our armed forces I'm inspired I'm
inspired by your courage by your
selflessness by your love of country and
your patriotism you stand here on a
frontier of freedom you stand tall and
proud in defense of our families our
citizens and our most cherished values
your mission is vital and today on
behalf of your commander-in-chief I say
to all of you in the days ahead
mind your mission take care of one
another
respect the unified chain of command and
never doubt that every day every
operation and every decision that you
make matters to the United States of
America Washington Journal continues
members are advised that these are the
last votes expect in the house for the
day the week the month and the year and
with that congressional Democrats and
Republicans leaving Capitol Hill as the
house and later the Senate passing a
stopgap spending measure to keep the
government operating through mid January
this is the story from the Washington
Post in a signal of growing frustration
29 Senate Democrats voted to oppose the
stopgap only seven opposed the previous
stopgap which passed on December the 7th
adding the frustrations lingered while
many House Republicans burst into
applause after passing the short-term
spending measure not everyone saw cause
for celebration Washington Post goes on
to quote congressman Tom Rooney
Republican of Florida that's why they're
clapping for a three-week CR just
basically shows that we can't do
appropriations we can't take care of our
constituents
home we just have to punt for three more
weeks so we can leave for Christmas said
congressman Rooney he's a member of the
Appropriations Committee who has pushed
for federal aid for citrus growers
devastated by the Hurricanes
for some reason that justifies applause
I don't get it
I don't get this place the story from
the Washington Post open phones tell us
what's on your mind
let's go to John from Trout Bill
Virginia good morning Democrats line yes
the Morning America and c-span I just
like to say that a true Christian and a
real president should always strive to
unite the people not divide them and
also I'd like to say thank you Social
Security for my Cola I'm going to get a
whopping twelve dollars a year I mean
that's $1 a month so thank you and Merry
Christmas let's go to Mike next joining
us from Richmond Virginia Republican
line good morning Mike yeah good morning
you know I didn't hear it in the
conversation but I think we can't
overlook the fact that the reason that
that big reason why so many evangelicals
went for Trump is because I'm not a
Kevin Jellicle Christian I consider
myself a spiritual Christian but I know
a lot of Angelica --ls and in talking to
them something kept coming up and that
was that they feel that the secular left
because you know they pay attention to
politics the secular left relentlessly
insults them the secular left
relentlessly calls them stupid for
believing in a god they can't see the
secular left loudly insults them
believing that a life starts when a
sperm and egg get given the secular left
regularly insults them for a variety of
things they believe that that gay
marriage goes against the natural law
that policy goal I could go on and on
but it comes down to that with is a
perception that there is a serve like a
superiority complex on the part of the
secular lost in the media and
entertainment that it
return the things that believe in
ardella greated and especially on social
media they are personally being insulted
by people that disagree with them Mike
thanks for the call from outside the
Beltway the Boston Globe signs emerging
of a GOP backlash in 18 with the
president seen as a drag according to a
number of polls suggesting Democrats may
score big gains we'll be covering the
midterm elections of the 435 House seats
a third of the Senate and also a number
of key governor's races NBC News with
the AP story on the developments
yesterday of that stopgap spending
measure Congress passing a temporary
spending bill to prevent a Christmas
government shutdown quote Congress
returning in January facing enormous
challenges on immigration the federal
budget health care and national security
along with legislation to increase the
government's authority to borrow money
each of those items is sure to test the
unity that the Republicans are enjoying
now and there's a quote from
conservative Republican Mark meadows of
North Carolina now it gets down to some
very difficult decisions on how we move
forward in the first and second quarter
of next year he is the leader of the
powerful faction of the hard-right
Republicans the AP writing Democrats had
initially pressed for adding their
priorities to the measure
but once rebuffed on immigration they
worked to keep the bill mostly free of
add-ons figuring that they'll hold
greater leverage next month again the
next deadline for Congress to approve a
spending plan is January the 19th on the
Republican line Denis is joining us from
Fort Lauderdale Florida good morning
good morning listen I don't understand
something
is this about Christianity in the White
House oh yes and your point is Medicaid
and Medicare and Social Security and
Santa Christiansted pricks and diversity
let's think we ran away from somebody on
Tuesday who in a wheelchair 32 years old
with a little Gehrig's disease that
makes Christian sense Denis thanks for
the call The star-ledger
how will your tax bill change question
mark wait until 2019 couple of things we
are waiting on and that is the final
schedule for the president before he
departs for mar-a-lago whether or not he
will have a year a news conference which
is typical presidents on the final day
before heading out for a Christmas
recess and some speculation that he will
sign the tax bill today
there had been stories he was going to
wait until early January we do know
there's a news conference by the Senate
Republican leader Mitch McConnell of
Kentucky and we'll have it for you here
on c-span it gets underway at 10:30
Eastern Time
also you can listen to it on c-span
radio and be sure to check out our free
c-span radio app again the Senate
Majority Leader at 10:30 Eastern Time
here on c-span gloria from Roberts
Illinois independent line as we look at
the US Capitol on this Friday morning
go ahead Donald Trump represents the
evangelicals so-called Christians I have
been conservative and Christian all of
my life and I believe that the Bible is
a book for me to live by because
evangelicals believe it is a book to
judge others with I was a member of
either evangelical church for many years
and I know who they are and as long as
they are in the church they can cheat on
their ways they can beat their kids they
can have homosexual sex they could do
all of that but they don't want anybody
else to have the freedoms that they
allow themselves to have that is the way
they live when they have a pantry for
food they send this all out to gather up
food for the poor and